so Magnus was playing Black
starting with the Scandinavian
and then yeah Knight F6 and Bishop G4 is
a Portuguese
and it's a Gambit because White's able
to hold on to the Pawns
and then after E6
Magnus just Unleashed like a amazing
sequence of I think it was opening crap
Pawn digs pawn bishop um Knight C6 first
allowing
e takes F7
so black loses causing rights but has
more things developed including the king
after Bishop E3 Bishop B4 with tempo
King F2 and then rookie 8.
and black is down a pawn but it has like
most of the pieces in the game
and then it gets even better because
after White's next move
Magnus did not
slow down or hold back
black to move here who can find the best
move for black I I didn't look at
notation before but I think I'm
remembering correctly that this this
move led to lots of fun
yeah good job to a few people in chat
Rook takes E3
[Music]
sacking The Exchange
but it's getting rid of one of White's
only developed pieces
and after King Jake's E3 Knight takes D4
sucking more material
um now we should note if Queen takes
what was Block's idea
I actually have to think about this
what was Vox idea probably Queen E7
Queen E7 king of two Bishop C5
or if Knight E4 then probably takes and
Bishop C5 still a threat
let's verify that
yeah White's just getting toast
uh if King D2 rook d8 and there's no
Knight T5 because Knight's pinned along
with a queen
so it's just a flurry of tactics like in
Black's favor
so white tried to hide with a king
but now this diagonal is open
and white doesn't have a darksword
bishop
and then Bishop C2
oh no White's Queen
material wise
lights it's still technically equal but
black just has a much much better
position
so it's Queen for Rook bishop and pong
after Queen E7 yeah this Knight's
attacked
and then it was about checkmating the
white king
or just winning more material
or just sacking more material rookie for
how many things did Magnus sack in this
game
what a nice game and why is this
paralyzed in the final position
so I hope people enjoyed this game yeah
I think I think this may have been the
only time Magnus played this opening and
the one time he does he has an absolute
brilliancy
against a grand master too
made it look so easy
oh Z Nation says I come here for Eric
games not magnus games
okay I'll try and deliver on more
games I play myself
all right let's um fix up the openings a
little bit play a scandi
scandi is
it's a relatively easy opening to learn
compared to
other defenses against E4
I'm playing this line this is um Bishop
G4 is called the Portuguese
a decently aggressive approach
the F3 I think is one of the main lines
oh goodbye to otaki I was working in six
hours good luck with work thanks for
stopping by
thank you
pretty sure I was showing I was showing
a Magnus Carlson game
maybe from this variation
trying to remember
Knight C6 is a move
Knight C6 there's D5
and there's some crazy lines here I
think I'll play Knight C6 D5 Knight P4
is interesting
this is very similar to the Icelandic
Gambit
well Icelandic I think is
what is Icelandic it's like C4 first I
think
but I think the inclusion of like F3 and
Bishop F5 is
I mean it should be favorable for black
so I'm essentially sacking the F7 Pawn
and after it takes I'll be down two
Pawns
down two pawns here
but I have more development than white
has all the pieces on the back rink
so this is actually a really cool Gambit
I'm attacking this
I'm ready to play Bishop B4 check with
tempo
I'm pretty sure this is the same
exact position Magnus had
I mean just a few days ago I was sharing
like a really cool game he played in the
Pro chess League
I forget his opponent he's playing like
some 2500 rated Grand Master
I think the game went Bishop E3 Bishop
E4 and Knight here
King here
and then Magnus found a brilliant move
after King F2
opponent taking their time
yeah I think it's already a very
difficult position for whites
because like the pawn needs defending
but it's also necessary to develop the
pieces I think this is like the most
natural looking move
we might see D5
but D5 I mean
I essentially have two threats to take
the pawn but also Bishop B4 Rook E8
like both moves come with tempo
that's possible we'll see Knight C3
and I should like start calculating here
because
it's getting interesting
so rookie 8 King F2
in the Magna scheme
I'm pretty sure this still is a Magnus
game
and the Magnus game he took on E3
and then he had some move like taking on
D4
and the queen takes D4
than Queen E7
I mean I'm relying completely on memory
here
along with a little bit of calculation
but I think this works
it's crazy to sack
I mean to first talk two Pawns
and then to sack
The Exchange and now sacking a knight
all within the first 11 moves
but yeah the point is after Queen digs
D4
Queen E7
if the king runs this way there's rook
d8 and there's no Knight D5 because the
Knight will be pinned if King F2 I pin
with Bishop C5
Queen would support C5
and after it takes Queen E7 Knight E4 I
think I just take
and I'll be threatening Bishop C5
I mean it does really help that I
I reviewed this Magna scheme just a few
days ago
so it's pretty fresh in memory I'm
pretty sure magnus's opponent played
King F2 in that game
or maybe maybe it was Bishop D3
okay well now I'm on my own
um
Big Time Advantage though
Queen E7
is one option
Bishop C5 also looks very attractive
I think I'll play Bishop C5
it just poses a lot of
issues for whites
like if takes I take back
and that would be double check
and the King can't really run because I
take and then the King has to align with
my queen
oh
okay so the Bishop's attacked
looking for discoveries
so I'm calculating
um Knight takes F3 King F3 Bishop G4 I
win the queen
and then Knight F3 Knight C5 I have
Queen D4
wait okay so Knight of three Knight C5
Queen D4 King F3 Bishop G4 King G3
Knight H5
is not quite made because King
H4
but then Bishop takes Queen with Chuck
King H3 Queen G4 mate or King G5 Queen
G4 mates
even H6
H6 is almost Checkmate King F5
yeah let's take on F3
and this looks pretty stylish
now Queen D4
I think it's worth mate now
oh I didn't see King E2 but I have
rookie Yates
I also have this and then this
there's also this move
which isn't a check but the trends made
in one
I think I'll play this move
okay I can win the queen
oh it's made in two
okay
that was a nice game
that's a cool opening
uh Gigi to Rio 2018
yeah white played like one of the more
testing variations against the scandi
uh is F3
I guess we can say against the
Portuguese
so it was a Magnus game
is it after C4
maybe it was after Bishop G4
foreign
oh yeah it was Magnus against vaiboff
Okay so
let me show this game and let's just see
how similar it is in the opening
so this is a Magnus Carlsen game at
three and then E6 Knight C6
as exact same line Bishop B4 King F2
rookie eight uh except
yeah in this game
Knight C3 wasn't played
but it's still transposed because Knight
C3 is played next
and then same idea
engine says Knight takes D4 is a blunder
but it's still winning
fast move Bishop C2
it's good to know for the future
improvement over Magnus
okay Knight D4 is um
also very winning
so engine gives
equal here except
yeah I mean this is much more fun to
play with black
already an edge for lack
so maybe two is the best try but then
Knight before
yeah I think like if I had this position
as white
uh G4 yeah there's something like
computer line with G4 that might be good
to know anyway that was a fun game if
this goes on YouTube I have to make some
YouTube video
um because I showed this full Carlson
game a few days ago it'd be cool to do a
mashup
showing the game and then playing like
the opening